we head into the final weekend of the
season with another absolutely perfect
night yeah sandy alamar just wants to
see this team play well he wants to see
him get through this weekend healthy and
i think importantly he wants to see
carlos carrasco pitch well so that he
goes into october with a lot of
confidence moran three for 21 against
indians pitching
let's draw came out looking two down in
the first josh bell who let's face it
he's the guy they need
swing and a miss carrasco strikes him
out and carlos carrasco with a 17 pitch
first inning mitch keller making start
number five his third since coming off
the injured list his last one was his
best one six no hit innings against the
cardinals so the bases are loaded as
keller has walked each man he's faced
and he has as patient a hitter as you
can get you know in santana santana will
make you throw it in the zone
and that's what you're hoping he'd do
he'll take those two outs for the run
that's perfect that's perfect
four six three no rbi cleveland gets the
run but so what yeah so what is right
runner at third base two outs found neil
reyes at the plate the d h
and he bounces his ball back to keller
how about that we'll toss the first
underhand for the final out two outs a
man on and the indians leading one
nothing as they batted the bottom of the
second delino de shields ninth in the
order
slicing away from polacco and he tracks
that one down what a play by gregory
polanco get them long arms able to reach
that one that was a really great grab
made the catch in fair territory there's
very little room
in that right field corner lino de
shields robbed of extra bases indians
with a one-nothing lead pirates batting
here in the third carlos carrasco he
deals and the pitch swung that and miss
struck him out so oliver
is carrasco's fourth strikeout jacob
stallings the right-handed hitting
catcher banning 254 the pitch swing and
a miss
struck him out with a good slider adam
frazier walked his first time up
i'll tell you what carlos carrasco on
point he has fanned four in a row
strikes out the side here in the third
and it'll be the seventh walk issued by
keller that loads the bases with two
outs might be his last hitter bases
loaded for tyler naquin
breaking ball line drive caught by colin
moran
this is crazy that's baseball two out
single for bell the pirates trail one
nothing and here's gregory polanco he
just missed driving the ball out of
progressive field in the second inning
here's the pitch to polanco
hammered to right field if it's fair
it's gone and clear the deck with a cup
of coffee for gregory polanco el cafe
hits his seventh and gives the pirates a
2-1 lead in the fourth wow and that i
believe was the slider and he was all
over it and my goodness that was
absolutely crushed
2-1 mitch keller and mitch keller
needs three more outs to qualify for a w
jose ramirez at the plate 3-2
breaking ball ground ball diving stopped
by moran from his knee throw to keller
to get the out
unbelievable it's really this is
unbelievable five more no hits five more
no no
innings for mitch keller
what a play crazy al carrasco's put
himself in the hole now bases loaded
nobody out josh bill one-two pitch swing
and a miss he struck him out
and that is big for carrasco
his eighth strikeout of the night and it
keeps the bases loaded now a double play
ball could get him out of it there's a
double play ball hernandez to lindor
back to santana they turn two and get
out of it
so each team tonight has had a base has
loaded nobody out opportunity is keller
done after five no hit innings eight
walks nick has his work cut out for him
just one run lead 2-2 here's the pitch
swing and a miss struck him out a
fastball
beautiful the outside corner 96 miles an
hour naked strikes out one two three go
the indians on to the seventh
sam howard takes over for the pirates
and now delano de shields
punts it
and a perfect bunt he's gonna be safe at
first
that is the first hit of the game oliver
perez on the mound now for the cleveland
indians adam frazier who has walked
struck out and singled
this ball hit on the ground passed first
into right field
and frazier's thinking too
he's headed to second base and he's
going to be there a head first slide in
the safe call adam frazier doubles to
right off the lefty ali perez and a
hustling double at that and now
brian hayes
here's a ground ball to the right side
and through a base hit frazier headed
home he will score kee bryan hayes the
rookie
delivers against the veteran oliver
perez and gives the pirates an insurance
run in the eighth it's 3-1 that ninth
inning is a little bit different he had
naked down in the count and he couldn't
put him away so there's your first base
runner tying run comes to the plate and
it will be jordan luplow
[Applause]
going deep left center field that's
going to be off the wall
there you go into third base and coming
around to score as naked when it's a
one-run game
luplo a huge turn around second and
he'll hold right there with an rbi
double it's three to two
the shields had the indians first hit of
the game
line drive base hit center field luke
blow around third with the tying run he
will score
and delino de shields delivers
with a clutch rbi single in the bottom
of the ninth it's a 3-3 ball game the
indians have scored twice
in their final at bat to tie it up
let's see if the shields tries to steal
a base here i mean this is when base
stealers come into play
there you go
go ahead
and he's in there safely
barely stayed on the bag
and you've got the guy up that you want
and hernandez very good with two outs
runners in scoring position
here is the 3-2
and it has a fair ball and the indians
will walk it off yet again
hernandez delivers with the two out rbi
double
and the indians come back from the dead
and win it 4-3
[Applause]
incredible
[Music]